from the Quran and Islam
a lot of nutritional wisdom is shared
but what is actually true
sura 16 verse 68
it's in the belly of the bees and is huge
healing for man
this is how the prophet Muhammad drank honey water every morning
and what appears to be the science of today
it is very healing for your stomach and intestinal system
and milk is also explicitly mentioned in the Quran
namely sura47
rivers of milk whose taste does not change
and here is of course raw
milk intended with a lot of nutrients
which has also been proven
from the democratic
founder of the modern
medicine and the historical
work from west
a prize but also black seed is named
black seed
bet as healing against all kinds of ailments
except Death
in addition,
I have been saying that people for years
should not eat pork
why not the protein structure of 1 pig
is very similar to that of 1 person
so the immune system
you see this as foreign
and the list
with health advice in the Quran is endless
namely sleeping on your right side
don't eat yourself full
do not drink while eating
and so there are 1000 more
to 1 examples of nutritional wisdom
that are in the Quran
which confirms science today
what dietary wisdom from the Quran
I forgot to report
let us know in the comments i amulila